في الثالث من ابريل نيسان عام
1973 اجرى مارتن كوبر اول مكالمه من هاتف
محمول في احد الشوارع مدينه نيويورك كوبر
الذي يبلغ اليوم 94 عاما كان رئيسا لقسم
انظمه الاتصالات في شركه موتورولا حيث صمم
اول هاتف محمول تجاري
اجرى كوبر المكالمه الهاتفيه باستخدام
النموذج الاولي الذي كان يزن رطلين ونصفا
وطوله احدى عشره بوصه
في البدايه قبل خمسين عاما عندما تصورت
الهاتف المحمول وقمنا بصنع واحد واجراء
مكالمه هاتفيه كنت اعلم انه في يوم من
الايام سيكون لدى الجميع هواتف محموله
وامضى كوبر الجزء الاكبر من العقد التالي
في العمل على تقديم نسخه تجاريه من الجهاز
الى السوق مما ساعد على اطلاق صناعه
الاتصالات اللاسلكيه ومعها ثوره عالميه في
كيفيه التواصل والتسوق والتعرف على العالم
لكن الهاتف المحمول الحديث لم ينطلق الا
في التسعينيات حيث تقلص حجمه واصبح اكثر
سهوله في الاستخدام
وبايقاع يسابق الزمن استمر تطور الهواتف
المحموله حتى اصبح لدينا الهواتف الذكيه
التي سحبت البساطه من الهواتف التقليديه
وفتحت افاقا واسعه جدا في مجال الاتصالات
فاتاحت التحدث مع الاخرين وارسال الرسائل
النصيه واجراء المكالمات المرئيه بالصوت
والصوره والتواصل مع الاخرين من خلال
شبكات التواصل الاجتماعي المختلفه
والتقاط الصور عاليه الدقه وغيرها
وبينما يحلم كوبر بما قد يبدو عليه
المستقبل يحاول التكيف مع تحديات الصناعه
الحاليه لا سيما فيما يتعلق بالخصوصيه
لم يعد لدينا اي خصوصيه لان كل شيء عنا
يتم تسجيله الان في مكان ما ويمكن الوصول
اليه من قبل شخص لديه رغبه قويه في الحصول
عليه لذا علينا ان نتعلم كيفيه التكيف مع
ذلك على الحكومات ان تقرر ما هي المعلومات
التي تجب حمايتها لم نصل بعد الى كيفيه
حمايه هذه المعلومات وهو تحد حقيقي
يعترف مارتن كوبر لوسائل الاعلام ان هناك
عيوبا في الهاتف المحمول وان هناك اشخاصا
مدمنين عليه لكنه يعتقد بشكل عام ان
الهاتف المحمول قد غير البشريه نحو الافضل
وبينما تستمر الشركات بتطوير التكنولوجيا
والادوات والاجهزه يبقى السؤال ماثلا بشان
كيفيه تحقيق معادله التطور التكنولوجي في
مقابل خدمه تحسين التجربه البشريه باقل
الخسائر